hey you know people I am Dave Rubin this
is once again the Rubin report and I
have truly two of my favorite all-time
guest Gena grad and jimmy dore that's it
that's a pretty powerful statement yes
yeah thank you you feel good about guy
feel great
Jimmy how do you feel I feel good that
you like me more than Ben that's why I
have a list and this week you're right
above man yes according to everyone on
YouTube aren't you the same people we
are the same people yes and I'm Jewish
that's what they always say
I mean orders Jewish alright here we go
people everything that you put online is
going to be hacked into or someone is
gonna get it that you don't want to get
it or the government is gonna get it or
the NSA is gonna get it or anonymous is
gonna get it or something like that this
time of course it's snapchat you
probably heard about this already a
third party snapchat client called snap
saved was hacked into this week and
about 90,000 snaps were hacked and about
6,000 I'm sorry 9,000 videos were stolen
we've got a little bit more info for you
the file was first posted online via
viral pop com which is a bogus website
thousands of people downloaded the large
file of stolen photos and videos which
was shared like crazy on 4chan and
reddit most of the affected users are
from Europe which make up about a third
of its overall audience and the victims
are split fairly between males and
females and much of the content is
explicit in nature also a lot of the
content might be underage so now there's
all kinds of other legal issues that are
gonna arise out of this so of course the
first question any time we do anything
on this are you surprised
I mean we talk about this all the time
between the hacking and the NSA and
everything else does this surprise you
somebody got into snatch not anymore
I mean I remember when this was
surprising stuff and we were all
terrified and oh my god how could this
happen how could you invade somebody's
privacy like this but no how can you be
surprised anymore Jennifer Lawrence said
you know I hope you you know cowards
cower in the corner and you're horrible
and you should be ashamed of yourself
and now that celebrities are saying it
you know I think people are paying
attention but are we surprised that
somebody illegally downloaded a file and
put it on everybody's snapchat website
or app which is an app
so like basically little kids can send a
picture of their boobs to other people
and hope it's gonna disappear yeah I'm
not surprised not surprised you know the
other thing Jimmy are you on the
snapchat I mean it doesn't disappear you
can't believe it you can't believe
you're kidding Wow
well what'd you think it I'll never be
president now that's it unless they
don't mind a self fellating president
anyway the point is there's an image for
you uh no this is great
bite what they shared it on 4chan which
i used to have a goatee when i had a
double chin but what's the question
the question is can you believe it I
mean like I'm just appalled that
somebody hacked is next you know the
next thing you're gonna tell me first of
all how is this y2k gonna work out I'm
still worried about that but yeah the
next thing you gonna tell me is that the
government's reading my emails yes of
course that means everybody everything's
public anymore anything you put on your
phone and forget about it I you know
yeah okay it's getting harder and harder
to feel sympathy for people because this
is so common you have to protect
yourself and it's not by doing extra
layers of security on your computer it's
about you don't take naked pictures
everybody should take it but we should
all take a snood selfie of ourselves and
put it out put it up there so then this
is over with I agree that don't you
think that that Jia is gonna do it right
now look at what I should have cut away
I've done this was about to be our most
viewed video ever Jimmy you could do it
too I don't I'll do it they would be
that but is there a little difference
with snapchat because it's skews so
young so it's like so the sympathy thing
that you don't have the sympathy maybe
for adults that realize what's going on
here but this really is 13 year old kids
I was on snapchat literally I got it for
like three days I posted my snapchat on
Twitter and people were just sending me
stupid pictures mostly of their faces
with crazy faces really but yeah and it
was kids mostly so I was like alright
I'm done with this so there's a little
sympathy though for kids because they're
just getting it and they don't know they
don't really realize of course right
yeah I don't know man I'm not a parent
and so in my mind I'm the best parent
because I don't have any kids of course
I do it better than people with
carbon-based children yeah but I'm just
wondering like how do you how does it
how do you let it get to that and I
don't know because I'm not a parent and
there are little free little will minds
will do whatever they want but they're
taking pictures of the butts the taking
pictures of the penises of take a
picture everything that are going oh my
god what have I done now everyone in
middle school is seen it I don't know
what you do just stop doing that yeah
Jimmy if you had kids what would you do
because every kid now my four-year-old
nephew has an iPad like all these kids
have this stuff that you can't stop them
right how could you really stop them
from downloading an app that you can't
watch these kids 24 hours a day there's
a name for that I've asked people with
kids about this the genies out of the
bottle
you know I mean your kid has a computer
it's all over with everything they've
accessed to all porn I mean I can't I
don't know how people breaks kids today
yeah I don't advocate I won't even let
my dog in the computer and you know it's
sad when I was at Disney Land yesterday
with a six-year-old a beautiful innocent
little six-year-old who is trying to
explain her Kindle to Tinkerbell but and
God bless Degrelle she owes what is a
Kindle is that the name of a fairy and
she's like no it's my Kindle like why
does it say and I get it it's awesome
it's technology it's amazing but it
makes me a little sad yeah are you guys
on overload with all this stuff because
yeah it's hit me that like I've got
overload calm I feel like that's
probably a porn site to overload is
something else Mara
no really I'm like totally overlooked
like I love Twitter of course that's my
main thing and then Ritchie which one is
gladly overload calm is a different
thing I want to know what overload calm
is everyone is pause I'm focusing on the
load part it's important thing okay we
got like for me it's like I love Twitter
we're doing this on Facebook of course
I'll do the Instagram once a day but I
can't take anymore
I officially cannot take anymore you on
board I'm sorry I can't take Facebook
anymore I am so sick and tired of
finding out all the different ways that
my friends are racists and [ __ ] it's
like oh I didn't know you were an
[ __ ] thanks for this test that is I
had a guy the other day sort of God talk
about the Adrian Peterson thing you know
he whipped his kid on the genitalia it
was no big deal he's a knight he's a
great guy
very different culture and but there was
a guy in Facebook going oh I'm glad my
parents beat me because kept me out of
prison I'm like you ever been to prison
just filled with people who weren't hit
enough kids Oh bunch of spoiled
[ __ ] say you know what they all
say it their trials hey it's my fault
spare the rod spoil the child
yes yeah put me away well I guess
they're at the end of the day it's like
we're not supposed to know this much
about everyone Yeah right like that's
the key to this whole thing it's
reprehensible if you read their diary
yeah all right final thought on this one
you guys see this right that went down
that's good
hello that's the new one now that's
their trying it's gonna be a minimalist
no ads but so like I saw it someone
invited me I had to sign up because I
was like I don't know if this thing's
gonna blow up so I got hello doc so
that's Dave Rubin you better follow me
on there because okay let's move on
Isis yeah have you heard about them this
thing continues and now there's some
interesting stuff coming out of our
media and our government basically that
the stories are not quite matching up if
you listen to what our government is
saying and what our elected officials
are saying it sounds like these strikes
are doing something these airstrikes but
if you listen to our military commanders
no it actually isn't working and the
media is sort of half between because
they don't really do a great job the two
areas that people are focusing on right
now are kobani which is a city on the
turkish-syrian border which is under
attack by Isis and the Kurds are
involved over there and it sounds like
Turkey's kind of attacking the courage
the Kurds are attacking the Turks
Isis is attacking both of them they're
both attacking Isis we're sort of in the
middle of it and then the Anbar province
in Iraq so it is a big freaking mess
and it's completely mixed messages and
we were talking about this a little bit
before the show I don't know what to
believe with any of this anymore I
watched the heading videos I feel like
either they're made up but I can't tell
who's doing them or if they're just
trying to goad us into war and now I'm
listening to you know Joshua and it's
our press secretary and I think he's
just a [ __ ] artist and everybody on
the news I don't know what to believe I
don't know what we're doing
take it away Jimmy well I'll say there's
chief there's the two things that I want
to know is okay so why are we there
what what are we trying to accomplish
we're gonna we're not going to destroy
Isis we can't get rid of them
they're people right with a point of
view you can't get rid of a point of
view so and why if Turkey has the third
largest army and Saudi Arabia has the
fourth largest why are we over there
fight now I say this before I told you
it's like now I feel like someone gonna
go because of this dummy like I don't
know I've been reading as much as I can
read no one there's no I don't
understand why we are the ones over
there doing this is because we have what
we feel like we have to fix what we
broke in Iraq but this isn't starting to
rack it started in Syria and it started
because of a drought which I've been
saying for a month but so anyway so I
don't know why that's the second thing I
know and you say the beheading videos
they must have known they're trying to
go to us that's exactly what they were
doing Dave so they knew if they cut off
the heads of two American journalists we
would bomb them why would they do that
they wanted us to bomb them because now
they're against the infidel they're
against the big United States so now all
the other Muslims are supposed to rally
to their side which is happening right
so I want to focus on your your first
point first which is this idea that
there are these other countries with
armies right there as you just said
Turkey I think it's the third in Saudi
Arabia is it the fourth I'm not sure but
it's it's pretty big we give all these
countries weapons why are we giving
everybody weapons all the time if
they're not allowed to use them or if
they just choose not to use them and
then we still have to do it anyway
doesn't doesn't it make us look kind of
impotent if we don't get involved
whether we have a stake in it or not
don't we just have to do I guess which
is pretty to show the world that we're a
presence and we're coming and we're
handling it even if we screw it up worse
maybe we fix it maybe we don't it's a
coin toss but if we don't somehow jump
in and get involved then people forget
were there good thing I'm saying this
might be the mentality that yeah but if
we're not somehow in the mix then then
all of a sudden we don't count our vote
doesn't catch so we have like an
inferiority complex about war like if
there's a war going on somewhere we
better get involved because we have
follow with war fomo almost fear of
anything out know that if you were on
snapchat that's that's what they're
usually snapchatting it's the
America does get blamed either way a lot
yes either either you're so big and
powerful and you couldn't spend five
minutes trying to help these people or
why don't you stay out of it it's not
your problem so who knows anymore you
know I think I think our hands are tied
but I don't exactly think we're
therefore you know altruistic reasons
yeah so what is it with it are we there
Ross all right why are we there is it
are we now gonna try to install new
regimes in some of this place are we
trying to ultimately topple Assad but
it's that I mean we were literally gonna
go to war with Assad and there we go and
now we're bombing the people that are
fighting Assad I mean that's how crazy
well that's what we say we're doing day
but if you just kind of alluded to at
the top of the segment where we're
actually hurting Assad oh wait a minute
is that intentional when we're saying
we're trying to cuz they wanted to go in
and bomb Assad last year we pushed back
we were completely against it but for
the record I think we were out in front
of that so they didn't go in but now
they got a couple of beheading videos
now we do go in we start bombing who we
say are the be headers turns out we're
bombing Assad wait a minute maybe that
was the plan all along I don't know
because nothing makes sense so that goes
to my original question how do you know
who to trust when you flick the TV
channels and you're watching this stuff
and you know you're getting propaganda
from MSNBC and Fox and CNN whatever how
do you know who to trust because I have
no idea anymore I have less an idea than
you because you're super smart and
informed and I'm just sitting here in a
green shirt television so yeah so but
then I that question makes me wonder is
anybody in charge does anybody know what
they're doing or is there some one big
secret thing that work that none of the
rest of us are supposed to know about
but it's happening behind the corner
behind the curtains or is the secret
that nobody knows what's going on
and they're just like that's crazy sort
of also so maybe we'll just uh it'll
look like you know somebody's in charge
yeah I just you know again a general
Smedley Butler war is a racket someone's
making billions of dollars off this
right now there's a handful of people
getting very rich who have been getting
very rich since 2001 and it's not
stopping right because we don't have a
draft so it's not gonna ever stop
this is gonna be perpetual war you know
what happened to all this politicians
saying we're broke and we can't afford
Social Security Medicare we can't fix
our bridges of Road we have 40 kids per
classroom because we're broke with poor
country or world Detroit don't forget
there's no water in Detroit and except
for the fact that we're the richest
country in the world by and we have a
twice the size the economy of China
people forget that yet we're supposed to
be broke we don't have any money for the
people but we have endless money for
bombs in the Middle East endless I mean
how many more billions of dollars is
this good
they say 30 years now we never even
discussed it we never even debated it no
one's even talked about this or what
what our goals are how we gonna fix it
what what are we even trying to fix this
is their [ __ ] territory
these are Sunnis and Shias fighting each
other and they've been fighting each
other for thousands of years and we
think we're gonna fix it with a couple
of cruise missiles yeah by the way we
just signed two weeks ago this agreement
that we're gonna be in Afghanistan for
another 12 years which really means
another 50 years
wait but just two more quick things cuz
I think we're on to something here why
is it that these countries then so why
is it what does it say about America
that we're so quick to war and I think
maybe your answer this already that when
they're not on our border we still want
to go to war but Turkey Saudi Arabia all
those countries they're Lebanon they're
they're literally on their border and
yet they're not going to war so what
does that fundamentally say about I'm
not talking about the establishment that
wants to go to war maybe or the proper
tears I'm just saying the general
Americans that are like let's go to war
what is the parking lot we don't we have
an experienced war on our shores that's
what that says we haven't been bombed we
don't know what that's like so to us
it's a video game right all we have the
only thing we've ever had was 9/11 right
but and that was just images to most of
America anyway nobody's town got bombed
nobody had to worry about their electric
electronic Grigg being bombed nobody had
to go through a war yet in the United
States that's what that is and they
think you know they're manipulated by
the media that wants them to be think
that it's okay and everybody they look
to in the media says yes we have to do
this so they think it's okay that's
really interesting so they're more
cautious because they're on the border
where they know if you go to war it
could just come back it what you said it
sounds very you know crystallizable let
the meat cake just bomb them yeah level
the place what are we talking about why
are we sitting around talking just I
mean literally again I was at Disneyland
two days ago and there was a man walking
around Fantasyland with a shirt that
says bomb first so this is what people
think there's what a lot of people think
I like how almost everything you'll be
able to bring back to something that
happened is Neil and it's really
American thing
okay last point unless because we're
going over we have no congressional
authority for this war well that's on
top of everything else they sort of
cheated us and they said well we were
already at war with Iraq keine so we're
just gonna let that go but then the
Syria war there was no debate Congress
went on vacation Obama didn't call them
back but he doesn't Matthew they're
supposed to do their job right give war
authorization so I'm more angry at our
system I think then I'm angry at the
bomb so like that to me they've just
utterly all of them the President and
Congress utterly failed us well do you
think they're taking a sort of relief
and that hey not my fault it's a system
of course that's what they're doing
Boehner is going well Obama should call
us back and have a smoke but since when
does he want to give a [ __ ] what what
Obama thinks Jimmy bring us home well
politicians are always gonna act like
you know cup cowards right and so that's
why this used to be a Fourth Estate that
would keep them honest and call them out
on their [ __ ] so they would always
worry about that I don't have to worry
about it anymore because the people
there bought the Fourth Estate the
journalists are all on the same side
they all want to go to war they don't
ask the right questions nobody's ever
asked the right question yet and people
like Chuck Todd and David Gregory say
it's not even their job to call out the
government when they're lying us into a
war they say it's the third job than the
top news guys in the country so that's
what's really happening that's why we
have such a dysfunctional government
because journalism the freedom of the
press
journalism is one of the three
professions mentioned in the
Constitution it's a linchpin to our
democracy of Free Press and we don't
have it anymore we have a bought press
so it's Kerr which is corrupt yeah well
speaking of a broken system I've got
something that's actually kind of
inspiring about a system did you know
that Darth Vader and several other Star
Wars characters are running for
Parliament in Ukraine yeah that's true
I'm not making this up this is happening
not in a galaxy far far away right here
on October 26 they are going to vote and
well we've got some video of some of the
characters that are actually running for
Parliament in Ukraine
Nedim Aziz the macho Sawa Darth Vader
candidate owner Odin de patata with
Internet party Oh Kramer all right I
don't speak Ukrainian but yes Internet
party so they're running on the internet
party they have all anyone that's
running as a Star Wars character so this
includes Darth Vader Chewbacca Padme
Amidala Master Yoda they had to legally
change their name to do this so these
people are now truly the Star Wars
characters that they proclaim to be and
they are actually running there are
several other videos you can find on
youtube if you want to see some more
their Star Wars commercials and well
maybe we need some of this in America I
don't even know where to start with this
I didn't I said no Dick Cheney could run
yeah you don't have to be born in
Ukraine to run in Ukraine that baby that
guy yeah I don't even know what the
words were but I would vote for him I
like that to get the lightsaber and
there's a whole harp yeah he's saying
something right there some and he
doesn't know how to play the harp right
can you see that you don't do that you
don't think pluck he was plucking with
the wrong hand so you say you're saying
that their commercials are as big
[ __ ] as our commercial looked like
it yeah I bet that's a costume and he's
not really darling do we first off all
right let's go with some silly stuff
first I mean maybe they need the earth
later because that's the only person
Putin to listen to right I mean yeah
they need the dark side of the force I
are these people legitimately insane or
is this are they trying to make a bigger
political statement about how stupid
this um yeah I think it's the latter but
I think there is some element like
they're realizing how ridiculous the
political system is and our political
system is so self-important and such
[ __ ] I feel like we need some of
this like imagine if we had some
character that actually could get enough
popular votes
- we've had bigger clowns no really I
mean if you look at all little gohmert
yeah this isn't the only country that
does this I'm literally watching John
Oliver last night he was talking about
how Brazil since everyone's required to
vote now they just make a joke out of it
they have Jesus Satan and a guy who
shoots lasers out of his eyes all on the
ballot yeah so you know maybe we need a
little more of this because maybe this
is the kind of lampooning that
we'll make people actually go okay you
know what this is what the people think
of us as a government we better you know
shape up because this is ridiculous is
there is that less is that more
ridiculous than our system here really I
mean with all the clowns and the fakery
and we all know it's [ __ ] I mean
when they do the debates and if you're
winning at the time they put you in the
center right and the further you're
losing but then as you start gaining
more popularity they put you more I mean
it's all the pictures in matters exactly
and the fix is in and we all know it so
I really think we do need something like
this to shake the system well obviously
the system is corrupt right so that's
why we get so it's clowns but you need
to talk about the debates used to be the
debates were real debates and they were
run by a third party called the League
of Women Voters well the course the
corrupt corporate and owned
Democrats and Republicans decided to rig
the system even more they got rid of the
democracy that was involved in that and
that got rid of the citizens so now they
corporately pick their corporate
hand-picked journalists to ask them non
questions questions which they get
before the debate beforehand and also
it's not even there by the definition of
what a debate is what we're seeing when
they do these debates it's not even a
debate anymore what was the old debate
the lincoln-douglas the lincoln-douglas
those were debates we're going to
challenge someone's ideas and go back
and forth and question them directly now
they have rules where someone's you're
not even allowed to look at the person
you're not allowed to address them
directly that's exactly what I was
thinking I mean what a bunch of babies
like hold on that's not fair
hey I didn't know that in advance B he
said it's super me so let's go to
commercial so I can reap powder and and
and kick that guy's uh you know helpers
ass that's actually a funny point also
that I think that because of HGTV it's
also changed it that when I watch the
debates now like when I was watching the
the Biden Palin one from six years ago I
remember thinking Biden had so much work
done in the hair plugs and that that's
what I kept focusing instead of anything
he was saying looking in the televised
president yeah
alright so Star Wars in the Ukraine last
thought on this dude do we give up on
the Ukraine what happened they had that
whole thing work out I thought it all
worked out it's good it's all fixed
right do that do you have any idea have
that thing
because we stopped talking about that
because you know the ISIS thing and then
Ebola coming to get us through Mexico
according to yes Ukraine super important
though it's so important that we don't
talk about it anymore
or you know the plane that went down
with all the the crime scene of all the
bodies that removed and whatever we're
done with that right yeah joking aside
last I heard Russia now pretty much owns
Crimea and they were moving nuclear
warheads there so you know hopefully
Darth Vader can fix that let's move on
to internet trolls there have been a
bunch of stories lately about internet
trolls and trolling that is actually
sort of creeping into real life now and
causing crime and and sometimes some
pretty terrible things so let's look at
a couple examples real quick
Brenda Leland was found dead in a hotel
room earlier this month after being
confronted by Sky News over her trolling
of Kate and Gerry McCann whose three
year old daughter went missing in 2007
everyone heard about that story Robin
Williams daughter quit Twitter after
trolls posted fake photos claiming to be
her dead father and former model
Charlotte Dawson who was found dead at
her apartment after battling depression
had been subjected to a torrent of abuse
on Twitter this is just a couple of the
examples now you guys are watching this
on YouTube right now you know what the
comments often devolve into for the
record by the way I want to say
something about our commenters here our
stuff is actually pretty good and you
guys are pretty on point about what
we're talking about it for some reason
we don't get a lot of the crazy racist
stuff and whatever so for you guys right
there do you know Jimmy you want to pull
out these people or attack Jimmy oh okay
my breasts are applauding because I know
they get a yeah yeah Gina's breasts am
huge on the YouTube anywho so some bad
stuff is happening though because we all
know about the trolling and the fact
that it's actually becoming sort of a
real-world consequence now is is really
kind of scary don't you think yeah I I
think that at first you know this was
just like a couple people and you know
everybody says the same trope well with
some guy in his parents basement he has
no life no money no friends well I think
the scary thing is these these people
are among us now these people are people
saying you know what you're famous
you're rich you're successful a you
deserve to be hurt you deserve to be
taken down and B you shouldn't be able
to feel it because all of these things
insulate you your
your your money you you no longer have
access to your feelings which is totally
insane and I don't think I'm saying
anything too controversial here by
saying that anyone who did that to Robin
Williams daughter and then hid behind
well you know it's my free speech you're
a piece of [ __ ]
there is nothing lower than what you did
okay so you hit a couple good points
there but you know it's just there's
such a meanness in the culture now it's
even hard to keep up go to any YouTube
video click on the fourth commenters
comment the fourth comments are always
mercilessly rips the third commenter
right and then the fifth comment or the
newcomer tries to find common ground
between everybody and for that the six
commenter impugns is sexuality so it's
it's not you know and it's all and the
racist trolling on youtube and the
people who are worse at that are the 400
Ricans I think we can all agree so
here's the thing if you're getting you
know if your tweeter that and it's
hurting your feelings stop going on
Twitter that would be my advice to you
if you're going on Facebook and you're
getting a lot of hurtful stop going on
Facebook those are all imaginary places
they don't really exist you can go
outside and have a lunch you could see
somebody going on the Starbucks you can
do something you can go at Starbucks and
go on Twitter yeah so there's another
part of trolling that I'm noticing now
which is people that are public people
so it's not just anonymous people
anywhere those are the ones usually that
are attacking everyone and saying all
the racist stuff and the homophobic
stuff but I'm noticing a new pattern of
people that are public people often it's
a lot of media people that are fighting
with each other constantly on Twitter
publicly doing it with their names and
everything but that seems to be the new
trolling because it's like you guys
would not do this if you were sitting
across the table from each other you
know I mean this endless bickering back
and forth and making a point back and I
beat you at this point and you beat me
at this point I think that's the new
trolling it's just saying [ __ ] that you
wouldn't say if they were right in front
of you well and I think that that just
it doesn't matter if you're famous or
you're not famous it's a gigantic
platform and it's like you're sitting
there with a sold-out house you know you
have ten thousand fifty thousand a
million followers so you have all these
eyeballs on you so you might as well
take advantage of the those eyeballs
because they're watching and they'll
listen to you yeah so you know as far as
the NMM anonymity of it Huffington Post
I think got rid of anonymous trolling or
they got it rid of the anonymous
commenters do you think we need some
element of that because maybe not in
America where at least we have free
speech for now I think but in some of
these other countries where you know
like Egypt where you know revolutions
are started because of this stuff on
social media they need some level of
anonymity right well what Facebook
Huffington Post did was they decided
that you had to have your Facebook right
so you have to sign in with Facebook so
we know who you are you know how hard it
is to create a phony Facebook profile it
could take upwards of two minutes Jimmy
maybe maybe a whole 60 seconds or
something so that's why that was funny
to me when they did that I was like oh
is this this is like this is this is
being screened at the airport this is
the guy patting you down here it's all
window dressing that doesn't really mean
anything if you want a troll you can
still troll yeah I don't know man
honestly I think in this country for me
I don't think there's really any reason
to be anonymous when you're when you're
being a commentary I you can see how it
can definitely affect people in other
countries and I'm sure they're gonna be
people that disagree with me I just I
just don't see it I just don't know why
if you stand and be counted
yeah wait so I did get my final thought
back which is jumps off that which is is
there some reason that we need this that
maybe these anonymous people who are
getting all this vile gross stuff out
that maybe that's actually better than
them taking it to the real world even
though now it is trickling into the real
world
it feels the real world it's not when
it's someone says something terrible
horrible terrible to me online I don't
go well thank God they got that out of
their system now that world's a more
pleasant place now I'm feeling reactive
my prefrontal cortex is going crazy my
amygdala is getting hijacked I don't
think anyone's better off because of
that Touche Touche Jimmy bring us home I
think he helps you develop a thick skin
and dismiss things that aren't important
and people's opinions you do you don't
even know so I think it's that's a good
muscle to build up you have to build it
up as a comedian if you let a heckler
get under your skin he's winning you're
losing so I just think it's one of those
things you learn how did the Union this
is anonymous this is funny it's learned
how to build a thick skin that's what
there's and if you can't build
read the [ __ ] comments that's all it
is at Jimmy underscore door on the
Twitter so let Jimmy know how you feel
all right let's move on Denmark is going
to outlaw bestiality yeah that's right
animal sex has been legal in Denmark and
people were taking advantage of it to
the point that there was actually like a
tourism based on animal sex believe it
or not 76% of the Danish population now
believe that banning sex with animals is
the right thing to do so they're gonna
go ahead and do it that means twenty
four percent is still down with animal
sex alright you know five one in one in
one in five four four four okay I'm not
mad I'm not am a surgeon you're not a
mathematician it's actually worse than
you thought Jimmy it's it's one in four
it really is
we've got a quote from Denmark's Food
and Agriculture Minister I've decided
that we should ban sex with animals that
is happening for numerous reasons the
most important is that in the vast
majority of cases it is an attack
against the animal that's a great line
and under all circumstances any doubts
about it should go to the animals
benefit they naturally cannot say no to
go along with it therefore it should be
banned I like the part in the vast
majority of cases it's an attack on the
animal as opposed to the lamb that's
been giving you the eye all week the
fact that he even felt like that was the
most political statement wasn't that
that was like the type of stuff that we
make fun of in America where they can't
really like say anything so they end up
saying saying that sounds that much
worse well let's just just oppose that
it was a it was the other way around
because I don't think animals are
thinking God you noted Dave looks pretty
good but that's against the rules
if if an animal attacked a human in a
sexual manner we'd shoot the animal yeah
so just my dog has hump my leg plenty of
times and he's a good boy
that's because you keep dog treats up
your right leg which is a little weird
Jimmy yeah it is a little weird it's
funny that they had to that was just
funny that he had to release a statement
saying why we're gonna do none of the
reasons are numerous numerous I could
think of a million reasons but I guess
the big one is because you're [ __ ] an
animal that would be the big one that
would be the big one don't [ __ ] fight
over yeah
doesn't surprise you that it's Denmark
like this is a first world country I
guess there might be some third world
countries where there wouldn't have laws
in place because there's a lot of places
on earth where there aren't we don't
know the system that we have like where
you maybe would go over there over the
law and it's so I guess fairly
good-looking people so I don't know why
they can't just have sex with each other
makes you wonder well this is a builded
Denmark NAMBLA Association the National
Organization of man-beast and they're
pushing back against this they're
pushing back most of it their hips but
what is the what is there a group
pushing back against this is any way
that there's anyone actually well
someone's got to be upset pushing back
more than four people are we being too
dismissive of the people that want to
have sex with animals I mean there's a
fetish for everything right there is a
fetish for you name something someone
wants to have this desk yes somewhat I
mean somebody that's room I don't want
to tell you but somebody oh no but
really there's a fetish for everything
so are we being too dismissive about
people that probably are treating the
animal you may take the animal out for
dinner yeah sorry out to the old feedbag
no because I mean in general if you're
with your fetish if your cork whatever
doesn't hurt anyone doesn't it you know
encroach on anybody else's liberties
then have a good time with the sheet
that's what I'm saying yeah I mean it
keeps going bad
they can't say no so therefore you can't
do it alright let's talk about the
latest in sex toys and robot sex and
iPhone sex and all that good stuff there
is a new app and a new a vibrator called
the we-vibe 4 plus and basically the
woman has a vibrator that she's gonna
stick in her and her partner or her
friend or a friend of the family or
whatever weird [ __ ] you're into controls
that app from a remote location but
don't take my word for it we've got some
video
I can't wait call me when you're ready
are you ready to give this a try
I've been waiting all day
yeah that's that's real that's real
that's happening we've talked a lot
about robot sex and you know that often
the sex industry leads technology and
you know it obviously will work with
interracial couples also which is nice
any thoughts any thoughts Gina so I used
to really get annoyed when you know
people would talk about sex toys and the
man a man would always say well it's
just making penises obsolete like shut
up if you're doing it right it's not
obsolete oh you think so
yeah I mean look he didn't even have to
be there he feels like the man he's
turning up the volume he's going from
echo to vibrate to he doesn't have to be
there he feels like he's getting it done
so is there some weird thing you know
people always talk about the power
that's involved in sex and one side
always has more power and I guess
usually it's the man that this it really
seems like you're giving all the power
to the man I mean this woman could be
walking around with this thing in her
all day literally and this guy can just
be buzzing her at any point Jimmy do you
want one for your wife finally finally a
product for women who are too exhausted
to masturbate right I mean no that's
this has been a big problem I've read
the articles in the Cosmo and what have
you and they talked about I would like
to press on on my vibrator but I off
there was just an app that my husband
could do it from you know some kind of a
public place that would be fantastic
yeah it's ridiculous and that saying
funny about the way they did that too
he's sitting in the park so like he's
just going about his normal day she
obviously is home and this is one of
those things this is like just because
you have the technology doesn't mean
it's worthwhile yeah like I remember a
guy who was a drug dealer in my
neighborhood and he used he bought a
Cadillac and he had a remote control for
a stereo in his car cuz you could have
it cuz you could have you could have so
you could have this you could have an
app on your iPhone the terms on a
vibrator inside your girlfriend's [ __ ]
but that's it's not necessary it's just
a bit much it's exactly what I do
remotely do it hey I'm sitting at a
fountain I wonder if I could get my
wife's [ __ ] hot
what
whoa what is that's it what what just
gonna change is this gonna change the
conversations between like grandparents
and grandkids cuz oh the only thing I
can think of is in my day we actually
had to be there three flights of stairs
to stick a finger in a vagina yeah
that's actually a really great point
because I always think about that like
my grandma passed away last year and I
saw these love letters that my
grandfather wrote to her and you know
when he was fighting in the war in World
War two and the stacks of love letters
and it's like just now Lou tooth so that
was a wire that went all the way to an
underground and the tunnels and 20
people died my dearest love stop Sam
here's there really were telegrams too
but really like they had to have this
long distance it took time for literally
the paper to get across the world where
now you can meet someone on an app send
you them their dick pic they can send
you the boob pic right then in there
like we really are losing a little
something right I like the I like the
hotel to do that via telegram please
don't stop stop please stop don't stop
stop stop don't you know if maybe you
live far away or if you're into some
kinky stuff do your thing I would
probably end up taking you know the the
D batteries out of a flashlight sticking
it in there going about my day and
texting later and saying that was
fantastic yeah yeah wonderful
all right well actually we've got some
images of the device so that's what it
looks like so what's happening so just
to be clear what's happening there is
the bottom part is going into the vagina
and the top part is gonna stimulate the
clitoris and you've got modes you've got
vibrate you've got pulse wave echo and
tied Gina you're the only one with a
vagina here these are the same modes you
get on the elliptical I like to jerk off
on an incline yeah it's really
I'd feed on it if you could pick one
exercise to do incline jerking I think
that's an Olympic sport I think yeah
obviously you go to the gym in West
Hollywood
definitely yeah that's where I go that's
a real insider I go to all of them
24-hour fitness which is not 24 hours
that's where I go it's about 24 hours
all right well anyway if you get one of
these messages in the comments below and
we'll I don't know maybe we'll get one
you won't run me out hey I'll go stand
over there find the TV you guys go at it
with the controllers and I'll let you
know how it goes TV is actually killing
you yeah that's right a new study from
the University of Queensland in
Australia found out that after the age
of 25 for every hour of TV that you
watch it cuts 22 minutes off your life
we've got more from the study
researchers look the TV viewing habits
of 11,000 Australians from the
decade-long Australian diabetes obesity
and lifestyle survey compared with
adults who watched no TV Australians who
spend a lifetime average of six hours
per day in front of the tube can expect
to live 4.8 years less the study's
author says that watching TV is as
unhealthy as smoking or being obese ok
so there's all I know when we do a lot
of stuff on studies people all jump on
the methodology of the studies and all
that kinda stuff so yes if you watched
it's not that the TV is killing you
necessarily we're that raised from the
TV are killing you but you might be more
inclined to be snacking while you eat or
then you don't get as much exercise or
all that so let's take into account all
those factors but that that being said I
mean the takeaway here is that sitting
around on your ass is not good for you
not good and I think it's ironic that it
takes 22 minutes off your life because
with with commercial breaks that's a
long half-hour sitcom is exactly 22
minutes it's not about staring at the TV
it's about you're just sitting there
being sedentary you're - Li shoveling
food into your mouth so yeah I could see
why they would kill you good god that
means that Three's Company alone
probably took a year off my life from
the early 80s that's terrible you know
let me one of my all-time favorite
comedians Bill Hicks made this point
that yeah yeah you've lived for and it
takes four and a half years off your
life but it's the last four and a half
years it's the fort or you're sitting
around shooting your green jumper right
who cares about those [ __ ] four years
right I'll watch TV enjoy my life and
die when I'm supposed to before all that
[ __ ] happens to me that's what I look at
yeah so do you think the binge watching
is making this even worse because I just
started this binge watching thing with
Netflix so like you know orange is the
new black and what's the one we Kevin
Spacey house of cards and now I'm doing
even Walking Dead and some of the other
stuff just we're literally you could
take a day and just from 10:00 a.m. to
10:00 p.m. just basically not moved it
seems like it's making it work I think
it is worse so I guess the question is
how long until that becomes illegal and
Netflix has to sort of deconstruct how
they do that and say you know why the
government you mean Michelle Obama is
gonna go this is gonna say you know what
this is this is if this is killing
people faster than smoking then guess
what you only get that one you watch one
there has to be a like another hour
before you can access the next one yeah
I often thought that there should be a
Surgeon General warning on According to
Jim
this show might kill you yeah but really
when you watch some of this stuff I see
to me it's like I watched some TV shows
and I just get enraged like there's a
new comedy that just debuted and I'm not
even gonna mention it cuz I know some of
the people that are involved in it and
Jimmy's probably gonna write it down
right now
and we can look at it after you can
write it down write it up she got it let
me see your okay so she got ready and
it's [ __ ] horrible it's a network
television that is just profoundly
horrible and I know so many great comics
who have worked for so long Jimmy Dore
included who who could deserve more in
that [ __ ] i watch it and then I had a
headache after it for like it doesn't
matter what it is but for an hour
eat that but really like I am for an
hour I was like god that was painful it
was painful to watch it was actually
causing a physical problem now
because you are in the same business I'd
like to have an attempt to do something
like that and you're saying wow they're
using this time to do [ __ ] like that yes
so I know I'm not this is exactly not
exactly what the studies about I'm just
making about me I guess yeah so you get
in you get enraged right and but the
shows that I watch I get engorged which
is a little different so you're watching
a lot of those what cooking shows or oh
yeah okay yes cooking show yeah would
you would you watch anything on TV that
makes you feel better at the end like I
just wanna strain this Rachel
I just started watching shark tank and I
do feel better than like smarter yeah I
do it you learn through you learn it you
buy some of that stuff by the the flip
books and the peanut butter anything you
know what show a 100 percent the time
makes me feel better and every time I
watch it I text my boyfriend tell how
much I love him what's that bridezillas
because a little bit of schadenfreude I
think it's a good thing and I despise
those people I despise reality
television yet here I am binge watching
it on Netflix and I'm thinking she is
emotionally disturbed and a crazy [ __ ]
he is some whipped jerk-off that doesn't
think he could do any better I am so
thankful not to be her and not to
attract him that I call my boyfriend
every time so much why I love him nice
that is nice all right well I hope and I
think that we might have extended your
life by watching this edition of the
reuben report Thank You Gina
Thank You Jimmy their twitters are right
down below Jimmy particularly would like
you to comment at him and write vile and
horrible racist homophobic what are the
kind of things you like and please buy
my book your country he's just not that
into you which I should have a copy but
I don't your country is just not that
into you it's out now it's a best-seller
there you go alright thanks for watching
everybody and we will do this again next
week